YUFENG GUO: Building a
production system of any kind,
that's challenging enough.
Make it a production
machine learning system,
and you've got a real
tough one on your hands.
But fear not.
This session will get you there.
NEXT 2018 had over 500
sessions, so it's understandable
that you definitely
couldn't get to them all.
And if you didn't see
Crossing The Chasm--
Patterns to Develop,
Operationalize, and Maintain
Machine Learning
Models, then stay tuned
because here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The space between a
model in development
and a model in
production is just
filled with pitfalls that
will catch the unprepared
machine learning engineer.
These chasms can be
crossed, and this session
helps outline what
to watch out for
and the steps to take
via four broad areas--
reproducibility, portability,
flexibility, and agility.
The first challenge
is reproducibility.
Training and prediction
data, they've
got to have the same
pre-processing applied to them.
So use tools like Apache
Beam, TensorFlow Transform,
and the TensorFlow
feature columns
API to help ensure that
the same code executes
during both training
and prediction.
Copying data around can also
cause all sorts of issues
when it comes to
reproducibility,
so don't do it if
you don't have to.
Use tools that will allow you
to join your data in place.
With tools like BigQuery,
Cloud Storage, Bigtable,
and Google Sheets you can
perform operations in place
rather than making copies,
which can help eliminate
these reproducibility problems.
Next up, portability.
Models are trained in
different environments
from where they're deployed.
Training is then
typically done on a server
with GPUs or even TPUs.
But then, when a
model is deployed,
it might be in the
browser via JavaScript,
on mobile, including
Android or iOS, or maybe
on embedded systems,
like Raspberry Pis.
So familiarize
yourself with the tools
used to modify trained
models for deployment,
like TF Lite or the TensorFlow
Graph Transform tool.
The third chasm is flexibility.
This can be interpreted a
couple of different ways.
It can refer to the model type,
data source and structure,
iteration speed of development,
model stacking, model swapping,
and scaling inference
up and down with demand.
These flexibility
patterns allow your system
to be resilient to
changing requirements.
The final fourth
chasm is agility.
Fail fast by testing new
ideas on smaller subsets
of your data.
Keep iterating on
your model designs
and update your model
as new data comes in.
Make sure you
version your models
so you can perform things
like AB testing, rollbacks,
and gradual rollouts.
And don't let the perfect
be the enemy of the good.
By making it easy to try
lots of different approaches,
you can stay agile
as the world changes
around you and your model.
Get your model deployed in
production successfully using
these four principles of
reproducibility, portability,
flexibility, and agility.
Check out the full talk for all
the juicy details around each
of these four topics.
Thanks for watching
this Cloud Rewind.
And if you like this video,
give it the thumbs up.
I've included the link to the
full talk in the description
below, and don't
forget to subscribe
for more great content.
And I'll see you
on the next Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]